everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today are gonna be going
over a match from round six that the
2014 came into this tournament our
featured players today why it's gonna be
played by shocked as we call him and
then blacks gonna be played by Peter
Svidler who's kind of had an up-and-down
tournament so far I was as I was looking
at all the games that were played today
I thought this one to be the most
interesting because it's a defense that
we don't see very often we got to see
the Dutch defense pawn here to f5 again
pretty unusual in my opinion to see it's
at this stage and the candidates
tournament here I can potentially see it
it may be a smaller tournament where
Peter Spindler is really really above
everyone else but playing its best
players in the world this is pretty
risky it was definitely prepared in this
opening which is always good my guess is
you wouldn't play it if he wasn't now
but still very very interesting play
from Peters Philotas position to have
such a weakness here but again the Dutch
defense can be pretty lethal of your
opponent's not up to the task of playing
against it shock plays pawn here to g3
definitely one way to attack it kind of
the the linen grand system where you
play pawn to g3 you fee and keto and
then you played knight here to f3
solidifying you or your king side safety
over here in a slice little way to
counter-attack the light scores in the
sin of the board which black is trying
to attack with this pawn here on f5 so
we'll continue with Knight to f6 Bishop
here to g2 pawn to g6 Knight to f3 as we
talked about be 7 being Kettering here
on the kingside Castle and then we have
castle all these moves somewhat expected
from both sides white now starts to
expand on the Queen side he's pretty
much done everything he needs to do on
the King side he wants to get his dark
squared Bishop out before he plays
something like a pawn to e3 so he wants
to kind of hold on to that as long as
possible so really his only move is to
go ahead and start pushing on the Queen
side get his knight involved into the
game see if his opponent does his
opponent on the other hand kind of wants
to do the same thing once to maybe
potentially start to attack in the
center of the board his King side is
developed he definitely wants to give
his light square bishop involved into
the game his knight involved and then
again see what shock does playing as
white so we have pawn here to d6 opening
up the door for the light square bishop
also allowing for the pawn to push
forward to e5 putting another defender
on that square right now 9th to c3 again
all pretty common moves from both side
Queen to e8 it's kind of a waiting move
it's not doing too much since the pawn
moves forward here to d6 it does have an
outlet here for these light squares but
again this move here on Queenie 8 isn't
doing too much white decides to go for
the pretty aggressive line and that's
pawn here too before pushing forward
he's just gonna really put as much
pressure as you can on his opponent with
these pawns on the Queen side now pawn
to e5 trying to break up the center of
the board we see the pawn take now the
pawn take and then Bishop here to a3 now
a few different options that White had
in this particular case you know he's
looking for the discovered attack with
pawn here to b5 he didn't have to
necessarily play Bishop there to a3 he
could have played Knight to d5
this again is pretty aggressive
attacking the center of the board if
Peters Fila decides to take either have
a pawn here he could play the very
aggressive Queen takes attacking the
King he could even push forward with
pawn to e4 even though we have the pawn
take knight take knight take we can now
have the Queen come up here d5 check and
we recapture this material back so why
doesn't it lose any material in this
position so definitely had options and
the particular game decided to go ahead
and play Bishop here to a3 looking for
that discovered attack with pawn here to
b5 we now see pawn pushing forward to e4
forcing the knight to move that's going
to come over here d4 centralizing
doesn't want to move too far out from
the rest of the field again white is
really trying to control the center and
attack from the Queen side so it
definitely wants to make sure he has as
many
peace is possible in the attack rook to
f7 again doesn't want to have to deal
with this pawn here to b5 and then we
see Queen here to b3 kind of opening up
the door for pawn to c5 if he wants to
he still has the pawn to b5 threatening
this long diagonal so just getting all
his pieces in motion in case black kind
of slips up Knight to c6 again
developing his pieces white decides to
go ahead and trade off again he had
moved this Knight away from f3 so you
know Trading it doesn't do too much harm
now we see palm pushing forward
attacking opening up this long diagonal
so this rook is kind of awkwardly placed
he would really like to double it up
maybe with his rook here on d8 d7
control this long open file right here
the Queen's going to come back to e8
after it's being attacked palm pushing
forward to f3 pretty much putting to the
test this pawn here on f4 also stopping
any attack of Knight to g4 which could
get pretty awkward in White's position
right here now we see the bishop come to
e6 again now black has pretty much
completed his development both sides
have completed development so again just
getting involved into the action rook to
d1 again trying to control these long
files that's exactly what white wants to
do and then black besides to kind of
counter-attack on the Queen side he
plays pawn here to a6 then we see the
capture and the recapture with the rook
here on a6 realizing that he can't just
bring it over here to d8 instead decides
to go ahead and put pressure on this
Bishop here on a3 now we see the capture
for this pawn on e4 and then the capture
and then the capture and we can see why
it ends up going up and material but
black does have a nice counter play and
that is pawn here to b5 if we just look
at this before we could say you know
white actually came up on top but after
pawn to b5 black's going to win that
material there's just too much pressure
right here white can't take with this
pawn because this Queen's gonna fall and
can't just move it at all because then
the Queen would fall so again this upon
is going to end up taking or the bishop
could end up taking blacks going to get
that material back so in this particular
case if we look at it I would say it's
about
equal both sides have the same material
they both have the double bishop pair on
an open board so they can pretty much
control a lot of the action it really
just comes down to if one side slips up
or not but again there's no clear-cut
winner right now Queen now moves to III
again being it's actually gets out of
way pawn taking on c4 we now have passed
pawns on c4 and e2 Black's obviously a
lot closer but he does have doubled
pawns something for white to keep in
mind if he wants to attack later on
Bishop here to c5 central line this
Bishop also opening up the door for a
potential trap this pawn is now open
it's for attacking but it would actually
be a pretty big mistake one that many
players would fall into but after the
rook were to take here on a two then we
nice to see a deflection with Bishop
here to d5 this Bishop here on e6 can't
do a whole heck of a lot it can't move
because the pin even if it tries to move
back the Queen could just take care on
e8 the bishop can no longer tape because
again it's still pinned even in this
position even if the root comes back
here to a6 trying to protect this bishop
now the bishop can take here on c4
attacking both the rook and the bishop
we still have the pin right here
the rook can come to a c6 and try to
hold down the fort since not being
attacked but after Bishop here to b5
pinning this rook down to the Queen
it just gets pretty ugly for black
White's gonna have a pretty easy game
from here so after Bishop there to c5
we'll see the Queen come over here to c8
definitely wants to make sure that
there's no crazy pins going on where you
could lose his queen but he still wants
to keep it on these light squares and
that's where his most central bishop is
we now see pawn to h4 again putting a
lot of pressure on the King side he can
start marching up the board and from
here is kind of where it all fell apart
black plays pawn to age sex and usually
don't see this type of poor play at this
stage but black just pretty much just
left this pawn hanging here on g6 after
the bishop takes on g6 there's there's
no way to get that material back as you
approach the endgame you can't give
material back unless you have
something in return for it black
actually has nothing in return it was
just a pretty poor play Peters findly
said that his mind just didn't work for
about 20 minutes this was in that 20
minute span and so again from here shock
was just able to play a few moves out
didn't take long from here so Bishop
here to the d5 pawn to h5 protecting
nice little outpost for this Bishop now
the Queen's gonna come to these seven
Bishop back here to d4 why it's pretty
much okay with just going down to the
endgame because he is up in material
right here rook over here to e6 Bishop
to f7 again pretty okay with exchanging
Queen taking SATs go ahead and take now
after the rook comes here to g7 again it
is being protected by this bishop and
the King moves that we have the last
devastating move and that is rook here
to g5 really really brilliant last move
by Jacque because it really puts Block
in a tough spot Peters fiddler was
forced to resign in this particular case
but to kind of go through you know what
would happen if the pawn takes here on
g5 we could now see the bishop take here
on III if you look at the squares on the
board where each side would promote to
the white pawn would come to h8 because
black does not have a dark square bishop
there's no great way to defend this if
you look at black his past pawn here on
c4 is going to a c1 which is a dark
square white has a dark square bishop so
he can kind of fend this so even though
White's up of material it it could be
stopped if black had the right square
bishop but he does not have his light
squared Bishop and that's something
wants to be a huge factor so this would
be very very difficult for black he
would obviously lose this game even if
we come back in this particular case the
bishop if he really moves it really
doesn't matter where he goes let's say
he just comes back here to c6 then again
the bishop could take here on III black
could be forced to capture and then the
bishop could take here on g5 this would
definitely be very very bad
if the route decides to move instead we
could see something it doesn't want to
come here to e5 because it would just
fall to the bishop but if it moves
anywhere else even if it were to take
here on e - then the works just gonna
swing over capture this bishop here on
d5
all of a sudden blacks down even more
material so no great way for black to
really continue in this spot going into
the endgame white just has a much better
game he realizes this pawn right here is
going to be a huge asset there's just no
way for black to stop it so Chaka was
not prepared for the Dutch defense he
said but he played extremely well as
whites
at the end of the game Peter Svidler
just made in my opinion just a careless
mistake that's what happens sometimes in
the chess tournament you've been playing
for four six days now in the sixth round
I guess seventh day they had a break but
his brain was just probably fried for a
short amount time made a small mistake
and it cost him the game so hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video always fun
to do commentary on games like the Dutch
defense
stay tuned for for more coverage and
I'll see you all in the next video
thanks for watching